[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العلوي
ضد
ايران
يدين العنف ضد الاطفال
منتخب الكاميرون يتعادل في مباراه مثيره
مع صربيا في مونديال كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
والبنت كون يدرس وتزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه
دقيقه وصواريخ بمدى 150 كيلو متر
تصريح
بين انقره والقاهره
اهلا بكم الى نشاط الخامس من العربيه رفضت
ايران التعاون مع تحقيق الامم المتحده
حقوق الانسان واسطه حمله قمع ضد المحتاجين
وصوت مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده على اذانه القمع الدموي وتشكيل
بعثه المستقله لتقص الحقائق في الانتهاكات
المزعومه لا سيما تلك التي ارتكبها ضد
النساء والاطفال
هذا وجدت الخارجيه الايرانيه اتهامها
لواشنطن ودول غربيه بالوقوف وراء هذه
الاحتجاجات فيما قرر الطيران استدعاء
السفير الالماني وسط خلاف دبلوماسي بين
البلدين بسبب ادانه برلين لحمله القمر
في هذه الاثناء ادانت منظمه الامم المتحده
للطفوله اليونيسف جميع اشكال العنف ضد
الاطفال في ايران ودعت في بيان لها
السلطات الايرانيه الى وضع الحد لجميع
اشكال العنف والكف عن حرمان الاطفال من
حريتهم كما طالبات النظام في ايران
بالامتناع عن استخدام القوه غير الضروريه
او غير المتناسبه ضد الاطفال الذين ينضمون
الى الاحتجاجات يشار الى ان ما لا يقل عن
63 طفلا قتلوا برصاص الامن الايراني خلال
الاحتجاجات
[تصفيق]
وصلوا الايرانيون احتجاجاتهم في شوارع
المحافظات الايرانيه رغم قوات الامن
الساعات الماضيه على المناطق الغربيه
خاصه في كردستان وسستان بلوشستان حيث
تصاعد قوات الامن من حملات القمع فيما منح
المرشد الايراني الضوء الاخضر
وفيما هذا الكرديه شمال غرب ايران قتل مئه
وخمسه اشخاص خلال الثلاثين يوما الماضي
بحسب احصائيات غير رسميه اثر حملات قمعه
لقوات الامن وصفت بالوحشيه ما دفع بمثل
المدينه في البرلمان الايراني جلال محمود
زاده الى الدعوه لمحاسبه المسؤولين عن قتل
المحتاجين بالرصاص بما في ذلك الرئيس
الايراني وزير داخليته كما استدعت السلطات
الايرانيه قياديين اثنين من التيار
الاصليحي بتهمه التحريض على النظام ولم
يتوقف في القمر بل امتد للصحفيين حيث
اعتقلت عناصر من الحرس الثوري مراسله
وكاله انباء ان الايرانيه واقتادته الى
مكان مجهول بحسب ما اكد الاتحاد الدولي
للصحفي
فاكيني
[تصفيق]
في الداخل بل امتدت الاستهداف في اكراد في
الخارج بزعم دوري لهم في تاجيج الاحتجاجات
الداخليه
من النيران الايراني
بعشرات الطائرات المسيره والصواريخ
البالستيه مواقع المعارضه في اقليم
كردستان العراق
خليل نادري المتحدث باسم حزب الحريه
الكردستاني اوضح ان نحو 19 عضوا من الحزب
قتلوا منذ بدء الهجمات الايرانيه في اواخر
سبتمبر
واتهم نادر السلطات الايرانيه بمحاوله صرف
انتباه المجتمع الدوليه عن الوضع داخل
ايران بافتعاله تلك الهجمات ضد الاكراد
فيما افادت المفوضيه العليا لشؤون
اللاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده ان
اللاجئين ايرانيين بينهم نساء واطفال
كانوا من بين ضحايا الهجمات الايرانيه
الاخيره
ينضم الى من جنيف الان لمزيد من المتابعه
والساده العلوم السياسيه الدكتور بابان
الياسي دكتور بابا نهله وسهلا بك طهران
استدعت اليوم السفير الالماني وسلمتهم
مذكره احتجاج على مواقف بيرلين التي
اعتبرتها طهران تحريضا وتدخلا في الشؤون
الداخليه الايرانيه هل تعتقد ان
الاوروبيين سيردون على ذلك وكيف
[تصفيق]
العلاقه بين
الدول الاوروبيه وايران قد وصلت الى مرحله
جديده
ونحن نعرف بان المانيا طيبه
اكونوميك
ان ايران اقتصاديه كبيره لالمانيا داخل
ايران ولكن عندما نرى المانيا والدول اخرى
بدات تطرح وما سالت حقوق الانسان داخل
ايران وتطرحها امام مجلس حقوق الانسان
فهذا يعني
بان الاوروبيين
عازمون على التعامل مع ايران
بموقف الاقوى لذلك اعتقد بان العلاقه بين
ايران والدول الاوروبيه
ايران
لان ايران ايضا ساعدت او زودت روسيا
بالمسيرات المهاجمه اوكرانيا
الترجي العلاقات بين اوروبا وايران
[موسيقى]
قالت انها لن تتعاون مع اي تحقيق ااه دولي
فيما يجري والمفارقه همم انه يعني بدل ان
تستدعي الدول الاوروبيه سفرائها في ايران
نرى العكس نرى ان ايران هي التي تستدعي
همم السفراء الاوروبيين وتسلمهم مذكرات
همم احتجاج
كيف تفسر ذلك
ايران
لم تتعاون
مع مجلس حقوق الانسان
واراد ان
يقوموا بوضعه حول ايران للتحقق من اوضاع
حقوق الانسان الداخليه ايران ولكن ايران
لم تتعاون ابدا
ولهذا السبب في النيران لا تتعاون ابدا
ولكن هذه اللجنه او المهمه سوف يتم
عديده لجمل المعلومات من داخل ايران
[موسيقى]
الاستمرار
عليه فعلى الاوروبيين
ان يتخذوا اجراءات الصارمه ضد ايران
فالسؤال والمساله هي مساله ربما فقط وقت
اللي استدعائي سفره ايران في اوروبا
[موسيقى]
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي بينيكانس حذر من
ان النظام في ايران سيواصل وضع التحديات
امام العالم واكد ان اسرائيل تحتفظ بحريه
العمل والتحرش ضد ايران واضاف انه من
الخطا اعتبار ايران مشكله لاسرائيل لوحدها
بل تشكل ازمه دوليه واقليميه ما رايك سيد
بابان بهذا الموقف الاسرائيلي هل ترى فيه
اي جديد ام لا تكرار لمواقف اسرائيليه
سابقه زائره
ذات ايران
وليس فقط اسرائيل
مهدده لدول الجوار مثل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه ودول الخليج العربي الاخره
كانت ان اعذر
لك يضغطوا اكثر على طهران بالمقابل فانا
تفهم موقف اسرائيل
كما علينا ان ندرك
الايراني
شاهدنا كيف يتعامل مع الشعبه وسكانه فلنا
ان نتخيل كيف
سيتعامل مع الدول الاخرى
فاس اسرائيل لن تتصرف
com
تفضل الضغط على دول اخرى لكي تضغط هي
بالتالي على النظام الايراني من جنابه
استاذ العلوم السياسيه الدكتور باباني
الياس شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
الى مونديال كاس العالم الان فقط قاد
البديل بنسنت ابو بكر منتخب بلاده
الكاميرون لتعويض التخلفها امام الصربيا
الى التعادل مثير بثلاثه اهداف لكل منهما
في منافسات المجموعات السابعه تسجيل
المنتخب الكاميرون لثلاثه اهداف في مباراه
واحده بكاس العالم تعد المره الاولى له في
تاريخ مشاركاته وافتتح اسود الكاميرون
التسجيل اولا قبل ان يرد منتخب صربيا
بثلاثه اهداف متتاليه وفي منتصف الشوط
الثاني سجلت الكاميرون هدفين في ظروف في
غرف دقيقتين هذه النتيجه ابقت على امال
الفريقين في التاهل قائمه حتى الجوله
المقبله
هذا واشهد المونديال اليوم مواجهات قويه
حيث يواجه منتخب البرازيل نظيره السويسري
ضمن منافسات الجوله الثانيه من البطوله
كما ستقام مباراه اخرى تجمع منتخبي
البرتغال والاوروجواي مساء اليوم على ملعب
روسيا ضمن منافسات المجموعه الثامنه في
المنجد
من الدوحه موفد العربيه ليث البزاري الذي
يتابع كل هذه المباريات والاجواء ليس اهلا
وسهلا بك كيف هي الاجواء من عندك وابرز
التوقعات لمباريات الليله لنبدا بمباراه
البرازيل سويسرا
لاعب البرازيل سويسرا اليوم وبعد اقل من
ساعه ونصف الساعه من الان طالب وكمان
نشاهد طبعا هناك الحشود الجماهير العربيه
الارجنتينيه البرازيليه وغيرها طبعا
المباراه وتونسيه طبعا بس المباراه راح
تكون في استوديوم 9 7 4 او 9 7 4 هنا في
قطر بعد ساعه ونصف الساعه من الان من
البرازيل وسويسرا عندنا ماريو قديمه هنا
الى الى الدوحه لمتابعه المباريات منذ
يومين سبورت
كان لحضور لحضور المباراه ويفضلون دائما
ان يكونوا اتفضل قرب ههه
بحبوا يكونوا يتابعوا الاحتفالات التي
تقام ما بعد المباراه طبعا عندنا برده
فريق تونس سرهم كثير واقفين معنا وبستنوا
عن المنتخب التونسي
[موسيقى]
ضد فرنسا ان شاء الله الحلو
طبعا طالب الاجواء هنا اذا اخذنا الصوره
بنشوف همم بالمكان هون كثير يعني
مثلا حضرتك
[تصفيق]
همم اذا شفنا في شخص جاي من اليمن اصلا هو
اصلا من اليمن وعاجب كندا ولابس المنتخب
الارجنتيني انت ليش الارجنتين ميسي وينه
وانا من الشباب السعوديين عنك ما شافوك
سعود اه انت صاحبه كمان ان شاء الله باذن
الله مع المكسيك باذن الله نعوضها باذن
الله
نعم طالب يعني اليوم زرنا صباحا مكان
اقامه المنتخب المكسيكي الذي تناول وجبه
غداء سعوديه
حضرتك من وين تعال حضرتك من السعوديه
بالمنتخب السعودي
بالنسبه لنا السعودي فوق فوق طيب
المنتخب
والسعوديه باذن الله فايزه فايزه فايزه
على المباراه
ههه اجواء اذا ما رحنا على البراءه مين
بيروح نعم طب هذه الاجواء طالبوا اذا شفنا
بعبق السوره اذا امكن ناخذ الصوره بس مبين
هناك جماهير كثيره يعني هناك شخص يحمل
كاميرا همم يلبس الزي البرازي البرازيلي
من وين حضرتك من العراق من العراق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بين اا الينا هذه الاجواء سنكون معك في
نشرات لاحقه لمتابعه لمزريات هذه
المباريات
الشوط الخامس المستمره في ايضا
وسط منافسه شديده مع واشنطن الصين تستعد
لاطلاق صاروخ الى الفضاء لاستكمال محطتها
الفضاء
اهلا بكم جديد حذرت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه من صعوبه الوضع في مدينه خرسون
في ضوء القصف المدفعيه الروسي المتواصل
وقالت الوزاره في بيانها اليومي ان اخرصون
معرضه لخطر لانها ما تزال في نطاق معظم
انظمه المدعيه الروسيه في الضفه الشرقيه
لنهار
واضافت الدفاع البريطانيه انا روسيا
تستخدم الصواريخ متعدده الاطلاق وتسبب
ضرارا كبيرا في خرسه
في غضون ذلك قالت اوكرانيا ان روسيا تستعد
لشني موجه جديده من الهجمات الصاروخيه على
شبكه الطاقه الخاصه بها والتي اغرقت
مساحات شاسعه من البلاد في البرد والظلام
وكشف متحدث عسكري اوكرانيا ان سفينه حربيه
روسيه قادره على اطلاق صواريخ الكروس
تمركزت في البحر الاسود وعلمتني صواريخ من
نوع كلمه وحضر رئيس الاوكراني فولد امير
في خطاب له من ان روسيا تستعد لهجمات جويه
جديده
قبل ذلك نفت الرئاسه الروسيه تقريره
اوكرانيه حول فقدان السيطره على اداره
محطه ذا فوروجيان النوويه جاء ذلك بعد ان
اكد رئيس شركه الطاقه النوويه الاوكرانيه
اكد وجود مؤشرات على ان القوات الروسيه
ربما تستعد
لاخلاء المحطه
العربيه رائد الاخبار رائد اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك اين يتركز
القصف واين تتركز المعارف قبل ان اسالك عن
المواضيع الحياتيه من كهرباء وتدفئه
يعني بالفعل طالب هناك جدل كبير بالدرجه
الاولى حول التطورات في مقاطعه زبروجه حيث
اتباين بين تصريحات الروسيه والتصريحات
الاوكرانيه ال- الجانب الاوكراني يقول بان
القوات الروسيه تنسحب من مقاطعه زبروجي
على غرار ما حدث في خلصون بينما تشير
الدفاع الروسيه الا ان ااه هناك اقتحامات
اوكرانيه من قبل منطقه انطلاقا من منطقه
نحو المناطق
اقرب للمنشئه النوويه حيث مدينه انبي
وان قوات الروسيه يعني هذه الهجمات وتكبر
بجانب الاوكراني خسائر كبيره وانها دمرت
من الصلاه
الاخيره هناك كذلك هي يعني الدفاعات
الجويه تتعرض الصواريخ المطلقه من الجانب
الاخرى ايضا هي الى ان المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش الروسي ماذا يسيطر عليها حتى
الان منذ انطلاق العمليه العسكريه في
مقاطعه زبرجر هذا من جانب وجانب الاخر
الكريمنا من الروسي على لساند متريبيسكو
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه قال بان كل ما تعلنه
الوكالات او اجانب الاوك
راني غير صحيح وبعيد او عالم من الصحه ال
محور الاخر وهو محور الشرق الاوكراني هنا
بالفعل منذ الامس حتى اليوم هنا قصف مستمر
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه عمليات ايضا
مداهمه على المثلث ما بين مقاطعه دانيه
تقول الدفاع الروسيه بانها
جماعات وتقتل الجنود اوكرانيين وانها ايضا
قادر على كل الهجمات وتسيطر على المنطقه
لكن التقدم الروسي الوحيد محصور في مقاطعه
مقاطعه ثانيه
اليوم سيطره طلاب على اربعه بلدات اخرى
والمعارك المحترمه في وسط المدينه حسب
الانباء التي وردتنا من الوقت ليس بعيد
كما ان القوات المواليه لروسيا ايضا دخلت
المناطق جديده في مدينه ماركا المتاخمه
لمدينه
الحديث عن اكمال السيطره على مدينه
قاعد بالنسبه الى المواضيع الحياتيه همم
يعني الكلام همم دائما يطول عن موضوع انه
دوناتك همم يعني لا يوجد فيها مياه للشرب
او مياه للشفع وانه هنالك نقص في
الامدادات بالتيار الكهربائي الى اين ذهب
هذا دقيق باختصار
يعني باختصار يعني اتحدث عن تجربتي
الشخصيه يعني انا نفسي اعاني من نقص
المياه تاتي المياه همم ساعتين كل ثلاثه
ايام نسعى نخرج للبحث عن المياه وهمم يعني
نستحم قليلا نستحم بمياه غير نظيفه همم لا
اتحدث عن ناس اتحدث عن نفسي لانني اعيش
مبدئيا في هذه التغطيه في هذه المنطقه
المنطقه بالفعل لا يوجد مياه لا توجد مياه
اصلا صالحه للشرب
والجانب الاوكراني يقطع المياه من منطقه
اسلاميه حيث نهر السيرفر
ومحطات الترقيه همم مناطق سيطره القوه
الاوكرانيه الكهرباء موجوده الغاز موجود
موجود كل شيء موجود المنطقه
شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه المتابعه
واصل حديث السلطات الاوكرانيه عن اشتداد
المعارك في مدينه محمود بنورس يدرس
البنتاجون مقترحا قدمته شركه بولينج
لتزويد اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقه صغيره الحجم
ورخيصه الثمن يتم تثبيتها على صواريخها
متطوره ما يسمح لكيف بتوجيه ضربات خلف
الخطوط الروسيه
المقترح ياتي وصفاتها تحديات يواجهها
الغرب في تلبيه الطلب على المزيد من
المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا وذلك في
الوقت الذي بدات فيه تتقلص المخزونات
العسكريه للولايات المتحده والحلفاء ويبلغ
مدى القنابل المقترحه 150 كلم ما يطيح
لاوكرانيا ضربه اهداف عسكريه حيويه روسيه
ويمكن تسليم هذه القنابل في فصل الربيع
المقبل
توم كراكو خبير الاسلحه والامن في مركز
الدراسات والاستراتيجيه والدوليه ان
استنزاف المخزونات الامريكيه يفسر
الاندفاع للحصول على المزيد من الاسئله
محذرا من ان مخازن الاسلحه تحتوي على اقل
من المستويات التي تسعى واشنطن للاحتفاظ
بها والتي ستحتاجها لدر اي صراع محتمل مع
الصين على حده تعبير
مع من بيروت المزيد من المتابعه لهذا
الموضوع المحلل العسكري العميد المتقاعد
خليل الحل العميد حلو اهلا وسهلا بك برايك
هل يمكن للبنتاجون ان يوافق على اعطاء هذه
القناه
الدقيقه التي تحمل على صواريخ ايضا مداها
اكثر من 150 كيلو متر لضرب اهداف وراء
الحدود التاريخيه لروسيا ام لا قواعد
اللعبه لا تسمح بذلك واشنطن تدرك عواقب
مثل هكذا خطوه
نعم في الواقع هناك امران يجب توضيحهما
اولا هذه الصواريخ التي
يتم الحديث عنها وهي من تراث جراون لوش
سمول دائما
هذه قنابل موجوده اصلا في مخزون الجيش
الامريكي وهي اصلا تستعمل في الطيران
لانها صغيره الحجم وبالتالي يمكن تحميل
عدد كبير منها وهي دقيقه جدا يتم استعمال
الانظمه متعدده لتوجيهها وهذه القنابل يتم
شرائها من قبل بعض الشركات
ويتم تركيزها على صواريخ اخرى ايضا موجوده
في مخزون الجيش الامريكي وهي صواريخ الام
26 فعندما يتم
دمج قنابل ال جي بي يو 39 والام 26 نحصل
على هذا النوع من الصواريخ الذي هو همم
رخيص الثمن ودقيق جدا الان ماذا لماذا يتم
الحديث عن ذلك لان تلبيه الحاجات
الاوكرانيه صعبه حتى المدفعيه من طراز 155
يتم الان يعني اعطاء اذونات بتصنيعها خارج
المؤسسات الحكوميه في الولايات المتحده
لان مصروف الذخيره كبيره جدا في اوكرانيا
وهذا ما تتكل روسيا عليه وهناك انباء تشير
الى ان روسيا ستقوم بموزه جديده من
التجنيد ابتداءا من 10 كانون الاول
المقبله بعد حوالي 10 او 12 يوما اضافه
الى
300,000 الذين تم استدعائهم من الاحتياط
والذين يتم الان تدريبهم وتجهيزهم ضمن
وحدات قتاليه حتما سترسل الى اوكرانيا بعد
انتهاء فصل الشتاء لان انا دخلنا اليوم في
مرحله الجليد في اوكرانيا خلال همم هذه
الايام وهذا مرشح لان يتصاعد في الايام
المقبله وبالتالي العمليات الجلديه ستاتي
خلال الربيع اي مطابقه للتاريخ
والاخذ بالتقارير الغربيه والتي تنقلها
رويترز ليست يعني من عندياتنا بان مخزونات
الولايات المتحده مخزونات الحلفاء من
الاسلحه والذخائر بدات تنظم همم تستنزف ام
لا هذا الكلام يعني من انه دقيق من انه
صحيح والهدف منه سياسي يعني ارسال رساله
الى السلطات الاوكرانيه ان يعني
بياض
معقوله يعني
نعم نعم هناك هناك مش ما عندهن الموضوع
ليس ليس ليس لديهم هناك مخزون الاخيره همم
حتى ادنى من مخزون الذخيره لا يمكن تزويد
به اي حليف لان هذا هو المخزون
الاستراتيجي ما يتم تزويد الحلفاء به
الحلفاء الولايات المتحده هو ما فوق هذا
الحد الادنى
وانا عارف تماما ما حصل معنا هنا في لبنان
منذ 10 سنوات عندما احتجنا الى صواريخ
دقيقه من طراز هيل فاير لم تكن الولايات
المتحده لديها مخزون من ذلك اضطررت الى
الاستعانه بالدول الصديقه
لاستعاره هذه الذخائر وتزويد الجيش
اللبناني بها لكي يقوم بعمليه الدفاع ضد
داعش
وما يحصل في اوكرانيا اليوم انا الولايات
المتحده ايضا
يعني تلجا الى بعض الدول الصديقه التي
لديها ذخيره امريكيه لاستعاره هذه الذخائر
وبالتالي
الموضوع ليس موضوع انهم ليس لديهم ذائر
انما لا لا يعني لن يقبلوا بالنزول عن
الحد الادنى الاستراتيجي المسموح وبالتالي
من الممكن جدا ان يسمح البنتاجون بتزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الصواريخ الجراند لونج سمول
دائما تربونز لانها موجوده اصلا وهي تخرج
من الخدمه في الجيش الامريكي وتستره من
قبل شركات تقوم باعاده تصنيعها ضمن ما
تفضلتهم وشارحتموه وهذا ل- ل- ل- يعني
لرفع جوزيه الجيش الاوكراني باصدار الهجوم
الروسي المنتظر هلال
العسكري العميد شكرا جزيلا لك عميد على
هذه المشاركه
خففت منطقه توشينجيانجا في غرب الصين بعض
القيود المرتبطه بكرونا في عاصمتها
اوروميتش بعد احتجاجات المناهضه لسياسه
صفر وافاد مسؤولون محليون في مؤتمر صحفي
يعني سكان المنطقه الذين خضعوا لاجراءات
عزل في منازلهم لاسابيع باتا بامكانهم
التنقل بواسطه حافلات لشراء حاجياتهم ضمن
مناطق سكني من اعتبارا من الغد
تجري الصين استعداداتها النهائيه لارسال
طاقه من جديد مؤلفين من ثلاثه اشخاص الى
محطه الفضاء الصينيه مع اقتراب اجتماعلها
وسط منافسه شديده مع الولايات المتحده
[موسيقى]
النشاط الخامس مستمره في ايضا
ما بين تصريح الموظفين وازمتي المؤمنين
والاشتراك يقضي اول 30 يوما في رئاسه
تويتر
اهلا بكم من جديد قال وزير الخارجيه
التركيه
القاهره قد تعباني تعيين السفيرين خلال
الاشهر المقبله واضافت انه من الممكن بدا
مباحثات سياسيه استشاريه مع مصر على مستوى
الخارجيه في اطار عمليه التطبيع العلاقه
نقلت رويترز عن مصدرين ان الاستخبارات
التركيه والمصريه عقدتها مباحثات بعد
مصافحه الرئيسين عبد الفتاح السيسي ورجب
طيب اردوغان في الدوحه على هامش افتتاح
كاس العالم في قطر
قبل ذلك قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان ان عمليه بناء العلاقات مع مصر
ستبدا باجتماع وزراء من البلدين وان
المحادثات تتطور انطلاقا من ذلك
كذا كان لدينا اجتماع ضيق النطاق مع
الرئيس المصري والتفقنا على اجتماعات
وزراء بلدينا التي سيتم تطويرها وتوسيعها
سنبدا الاجتماعات على نطاق ضيق ومن ثم
سنتبادل الزيارات ونطورها كذلك الامر
بالنسبه لسوريا يمكن ان يحدث نفس الشيء
كما حصل مع مصر وهناك امكانيه الى عوده
الامر الى نصابها مع سوريا
معي من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه الان
حول هذا الموضوع الدكتور عماد جاد وهو عضو
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في البرلمان المصري
سابقا دكتور عماد اهلا وسهلا بك نشرت
الخامسه من العربيه قبل ان اسالك عن
حيثيات ومضامين هذا الاعلان التركي هل
لتوقيت من حيث التوقيت هل هي توقيت
الاعلان عن عوده السفيرين او قرب عوده
السفراء بين البلدين دلالات معينه مرتبطه
باستحقاقات اقليميه ما
مؤكد همم هناك استحقاقات اقليميه همم
غرس الجميع في المنطقه فيها ولم يستطع احد
همم تقديم وجهه نظره او تمريره وجهه نظره
همم بدل جميع اجهزه ومن ثم همم بدات
الاتصالات اا اتصور ان همم من المعلومات
التي نشرت مؤخرا بالامس تحديدا ان هناك
لقاء انفرادي بين اردوغان والسيسي لمده 45
دقيقه ثم معلومات اخرى ان لقاء على
المستوى الاستخبارات بين البلديل معنى ذلك
ان هناك تحركات جديه همم بمبادره من
الجانب التركي لان المطالب في اغلبها
ومعظمها مطالب مصريه تتعلق بالشان الخاص
المصري الداخلي وتتعلق بايضا اوضاع
اقليميه بالتحديد في ليبيا وبالتالي همم
تركيا لها مطالب تت من شرق المتوسط تتعلق
بتطوير العلاقات لا
الجانب التركي بدا ال- همم يعني بدا
المواقف السلبيه وهو من بدا التراجع عن
المواقف السلبيه لذلك تاتي معظم التصريحات
من الجانب التركي ولا تصريحات من الجانب
المصري لان الجانب المصري سمع كثيرا
تصريحات لكن على ارض الواقع هنا خطوات
تركيه بطيئه للغايه في التجاوب مع المطالب
المصريه يعني هذا الذي كنت ساسالك انا
اياه انه همم ما عدا مما بدا تبدي انقر
هذا الانفتاح العلني لاعاده ااه العلاقات
وما السر همم ولكن اجبت عليها في السؤال
الاول طيب همم في مفارقه هذا يجب توقف
عليها يا دكتور عماد انه المرونه التركيه
ازاء القاهره تقابل عم نشوف ايضا في مرونه
تركيا
ازاء سوريا هل يمكن يعني شفنا تصريحات
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان انه لا قطيعه في
السياسه
ممكن اعاده العلاقات مع سوريا هل يجب
الربط بين مسار انقره القاهره مع مسار
انقره دمشق ام لا يجب الربط بين هذين
المسارين
لا اعتقد انه يمكن الربط بين المسارين
يمكن الربط بين المسار انقره القاهره
انقره طرابلس هذا الامر هو الذي يمكن ان
يؤثر في العلاقات لكن اذا كان اردوغان
لديه توجه
بالتهدئه وصفر مشاكل مع دول الجوار هو
ايضا بصرف النظر عن موقفنا من النظام بشار
الاسد هو الذي بدا العداء هو الذي بدا
الخلاف هو الذي صعده هو الذي يعتدي على
الاراضي السوريه والذي يرفض التفاهم هو
الذي تحدث عن يعني بشكل سلبي للغايه يعني
هو من قام بالعداء تجاه سوريا بصدفه النظر
عن موقفنا من النظام لكن همم انفتاحه على
النظام السوري كانت هناك علاقات جيده
للغايه ما بين تركيا
الغوا التاشيره المتبادله وما الى ذلك ثم
فجاه بعد 2011 باقدر اردوغان بها العداء
لسوريا هو ربما يريد ان يرسل رساله بان ما
تحدث عنه وزير الخارجيه الاسبق ورئي وزراء
الاسبق بصفر مشاكل لتركيا هو انه اخيرا
سيبدا صفر مشاكل مع عالمنا العرب بدا مع
السعوديه مع الامارات تحرك اتجاه مصر
ويتحرك الان تجاهل سوريا ونتمنى ان يتم
ذلك تجاه العراق من القاهره دكتور عماد
جاد عضو مجلس الشؤون الخارجيه في امان
المصري سابقا شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور عماد
على هذه المشاركه
تستمر القوات الامن الصوماليه في محاصره
فندق يقع وسط العاصمه مجاديش وحياته يتحسن
عناصر من حركه الشباب منذ ليله امس وذكرت
قوه الامن ان الحصار اصفر عن مقتل اربعه
اشخاص وما يزال يسمع دوريهم فيجارات
واطلاق نار منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى حول
هذا الفندق الذي يرتاد وهو عاده
البرلمانيون وكبار المسؤولين ويقعوا على
مسافه قريبه من مكاتب الرئيس الصومالي حسن
الشيخ محمود يعني في هذا فيما علق
البرلمان الصومالي جلساته اليوم بسبب
الوضع الامني
معي من مقديشو الام راس العربيه عبد
الرحمن بخاري عبد الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك عبد الرحمن وهل تم
اقتحام هذا الفندق وانتهت الازمه ام لا
الوضع ما زال على حاله
عبد الرحمن هل تسمعني
عبد الرحمن انت على الهواء
يبدو ان الاتصال
تسمعني الان يا عبد الرحمن اعيد عليك
السؤال جديد المشهد من عندك هل تم اقتحام
هذا الفندق وانتهت الازمه ام لا الوضع
مازال على حاله
نعم طالب من الشرطه نقدمه
السيطره على الفندق الكامله وان جميع
الحريم الذين
نخدمهم دون ان
تضحكم لكن الشرطه وحدات خاصه من الشرطه
الصوماليه تمكن من السيطره على الفندق
انهاء الهجوم على الاستمرار لساعات طويله
همم
توصل هؤلاء الى هذه
الفندق الغريب جدا من القصر الرئاسي لكن
الذي يؤكده انه اعتذر عن مكان
اداره الحكوميه من مقاديش مراسل العربيه
عبد الرحمن بخاري شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المتابعه عبد الرحمن
اعلن ولي العهد السعوديه الامير محمد بن
سلمان اطلاق المخطط العامه مطار الملك
الملك سلمان الدولي وسيشم المطار الجديد
في دعم خطه المملكه لتكون مدينه الرياض
ضمن اكبر 10 اقتصادات مدن في العالم
وسيكون مطار الملك سلمان واحدا من اكبر
المطارات في العالم وسيمتد على مساحه
تقارب سبعه وخمسين كيلومترا مربعا حيث
سيشمل سته مدارس طيران اضافه الى 12 كلم
مربعا من المراه وسيعمل المطار على رفع
طاقه الاستيعابيه لتصل الى 120 مليون
مسافر بحلول عام 2030 ومن المتوقع ان يسهم
المشروع بحوالي سبعه 27 مليار ريال سنويا
في الناتج المحلي الاجمالي غير النفطي ضمن
رؤيه المملكه 20 30
الغد حركه طالبان في باكستان العمل باتفاق
وقفه اطلاق النار مع الحكومه التي تم
التوصل اليه في يونيو الماضي وقالت الحركه
في بين لها انها اصدرت اوامر لعناصرها بشن
هجمات في جميع انحاء البلاد ردا على
ملاحقات تقوم بها الحكومه الباكستانيه
في تويتر وقبل شهر من الان دخل الملياردير
الامريكيه الى النص مقر المنصه في سان
فرانسيسكو والتي باتت منذ ذلك الحين محطه
انظار الجميع حيث لاحقتها الازمات
المتتاليه
[موسيقى]
الخامسه من العربيه انتهت اطيب التحيات
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]